[Music]
we were just warming up yeah okay okay
I've heard it I've heard enough 1 2 3 4
where's Cal last evening I liked that
honesty that's what I need to see you've
got the free lands on touch that feel it
is it you've gotta calm down
there's people back home wishing to be
in your position and I chose you I
expect you to deliver you're gonna work
your socks off and that's what it means
to play for your country
Carl's late he's gonna find out you see
your stats here your pass is 83 well
when I watch you last time you didn't
really want to pass the book mr. Barco
pace ain't really your strokes is it no
you're a leader some people call me the
young Rio Ferdinand sir I don't want to
hear that 85 dissents probably a bit
over the mark I think you can get there
can you play football I'm giving you an
opportunity here because the New Age
they play in their bedrooms but I want
them to have an inspiration I might have
to someone to look up to say you know
what I can do that I can go out and
represent my country on the pitch we're
gonna show you around the facility and
I've walked Marcus Marcus he's given up
a bit of his time so I expect respect
I'm the past this is the present let's
go guys come on let's go please get down
you got understand where you are this
facilities for the elite Marcus what's
it like in a gym you're going to gym to
improve yourself you know you have to
get the best out yourself an outfit
listen no this is coming from my man
who's currently England international
Manchester United striker on the bikes
just go get warm up
come on this code we're gonna go outside
all right enough how important is a
warm-up Marcus no that's what prepares
you for the main stage so you have to
prepare like you're on a place so
exactly so concentrate number we got a
lot of work here one two three you stop
poking he's touching the bar way too
often
that's Bell stop a minute guys whoa whoa
whoa what is this how you can get a
juggle I don't want to see no wave and
get a jog on get in here now please you
need to explain to me why you're late
I've given you the opportunity where to
where the free Lions and you're coming
in here jogging like this like it's a
joke a late night after you got selected
to come in a squad with the free lines
on your chest you had a late night
furthermore take a jog let's go to next
exercise please a football work we've
got to do now object is to get as many
points as you can before you score a
goal the more points you get is
determine about how many passes you do
and I'm on both teams yeah I'm on the
team who's got the ball you've ever got
talent you do
can we come guys silence please
yeah you're too fun to talking I should
last session now before we go to Russia
this is where it gets real if it gets
serious you're gonna have this man with
you it's all on you then free lions what
it means back home get on that plane
trophy home okay smelly like need a wash
I'll get some char Joe on and go hey
under the armpit stay still stay still
for guy we have to break that down me
Ivan trios a top manager and is that a
hard job whipping him into shape because
as you can see they like to enjoy
themselves but going there now they've
got the right mindset and the right
frame to em go and do something special
well okay see the attitude needs working
on us to pull off these guys well on
that plane we'll see what happens on the
plane some people choose a joke this
isn't a joke
I mean something
[Music]